use your lightning gun as much as
possible it's the most powerful weapon
in your arsenal when the battery runs
out start deploying arc mines arc mines
should be hidden out of sight in bushes
or at the tops of cliffs however during
combat place your arc mines in the open
for teammates to retreat to if they're
in trouble
switch to your assault rifle while you
are trying to get close enough to use
the lightning gun don't trigger your
personal shield too early your meta can
heal you back to full health while
you're shielded so don't be afraid to
take a few hits before activating it
you can still trigger your personal
shield after being in capped use it to
keep the monster from finishing you off
and give your medic a chance to get you
back on your feet
use your flamethrower as often as
possible
when the monster is too far for the
flamethrower switch to your minigun
the flamethrower is your most powerful
weapon as well as the most visible when
a teammate is in trouble use that to
your advantage like the monster up and
force it to retreat
use your minigun to exploit holes in the
monster's armor remember to get close to
the monster the minigun has more range
than the flamethrower but not by much
don't trigger your personal shield too
early your medic can heal you back to
full health while you're shielded so
don't be afraid to take a few hits
before activating it a good monster will
hide around corners and try to fight in
areas where it has an advantage use the
toxic Renae to flush the monster out and
force it to fight on your terms
toxic clouds will slow down allies be
careful where you throw your toxic
grenade especially if the monster is
trying to escape throw your toxic
grenades on endcap teammates the extra
damage may be enough to drive the
monster away before it can finish them
off
make the most of your super soldier
ability trigger it in open areas where
you have clear line-of-sight and plenty
of room to dodge around try not to get
knocked down as you'll lose valuable
seconds recovering instead of dealing
damage remember that your super soldier
ability comes at the cost of some of
your own health pair up with a good
medic get up close with the combat
shotgun and when out of range
switch to the multi fire rocket launcher
while repositioning
you